♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THIS IS A BEWILDERING MOMENT AS
WE OFTEN NOTE, WHAT EXACTLY IS
GOING ON?
THERE'S A PATTERN.
YOU LOOK AROUND FOR A MOMENT,
YOU MAY NOTICE THINGS THAT ADD
UP.
INFLATION, SPIRALING CRIME,
COLLAPSING THE CITIES.
YOU'RE OVER 40, IT COULD LOOK
FAMILIAR.
IT'S THE 1970s BUT WITHOUT THE
FREE-SPEECH AND RUNNING OUR
GOVERNMENT.
AS IF IT COULDN'T GET MORE
PERFECT, NOW WE HAVE ANOTHER
FALL OF SAIGON.
YOU ARE WATCHING TELEVISION IN
APRIL OF 1975, HE WILL REMEMBER
IT WELL.
THE SINGLE MOST HUMILIATING DAY
IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES ABROAD.
AMERICAN OFFICIALS FLEEING IN
TERROR AS AN ARMY SWEPT THROUGH
THE CAPITAL CITY.
DESPERATE CIVILIANS CLINGING TO
HELICOPTERS AS THEY TOOK OFF
FROM THE ROOF OF THE
U.S. EMBASSY.
IT WAS A COMPLETE DISASTER,
TOTAL DEFEAT.
WE SPENT MORE THAN A DECADE IN
VIETNAM AND AN END, WE LOST SO
NO MATTER HOW YOU FELT ABOUT
THAT, IT WAS PAINFUL TO SEE IT
HAPPEN AND NOBODY WANTS TO SEE
IT AGAIN.
LAST MONTH, JOE BIDEN PROMISED
WE NEVER WILL SEE IT AGAIN.
WATCH.
>> SOME VIETNAMESE VETERANS SEE
ECHOES OF THEIR EXPERIENCE IN
THIS WITHDRAWAL OF AFGHANISTAN,
DO YOU SEE ANY PARALLELS BETWEEN
THIS WITHDRAWAL AND WHAT
HAPPENED IN VIETNAM?
>> NONE WHATSOEVER, ZERO.
WHAT YOU HAVE IS BREAKING
THROUGH THE GATES OF OUR
EMBASSY, SIX IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN.
THE TALIBAN IS NOT THE
NORTH VIETNAMESE ARMY, NOT
REMOTELY COMPARABLE IN TERMS OF
CAPABILITY.
THERE CAN BE NO CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE YOU WILL SEE PEOPLE BEING
LIFTED OFF THE ROOF OF AN
EMBASSY OF THE UNITED STATES
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
IT IS NOT AT ALL COMPARABLE.
>> Tucker: IS NOT COMPARABLE.
THE DIFFERENCE, JOE BIDEN TOLD
US IS THAT IN AFGHANISTAN, WE
CAN RELY ON THE AFGHAN SECURITY
FORCES TO KEEP THE SAVAGES AT
BAY.
THEY'VE GOTTEN BILLIONS IN U.S.
TAX DOLLARS OVER 20 YEARS AND BY
THE WAY, THEY WERE TRAINED BY
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS
OF STAFF SO WE ARE GOOD, DON'T
WORRY.
LAST MONTH, LET HIS PERSONAL
STAMP OF APPROVAL TO THE AFGHAN
SECURITY FORCES.
WATCH.
>> THE AFGHAN SECURITY FORCES
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
SUFFICIENTLY FIGHT AND DEFEND
THEIR COUNTRY.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE AFGHAN SECURITY FORCES WERE
NECESSARY IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
GUIDANCE WHEN THE PRESIDENT AND
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
THE FUTURE AFGHANISTAN IS
SQUARELY IN THE HANDS OF THE
AFGHAN PEOPLE AND THERE ARE A
RANGE OF POSSIBLE OUTCOMES IN
AFGHANISTAN I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
REPEATEDLY AND I SAID THIS
BEFORE THE NEGATIVE OUTCOME IS
NOT A FOREGONE CONCLUSION.
>> Tucker: IS NOT A FOREGONE
CONCLUSION.
AT THIS POINT, A MILITARY
TAKEOVER IS STARTING TO LOOK
LIKE A FOREGONE CONCLUSION.
THEY NOW HAVE CONTROL OVER A
MAJORITY OF THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING THE SECOND LARGEST
CITY.
THE GOVERNMENT MEANWHILE
CONTROLS JUST ABOUT 15% OF THE
DISTRICTS IN AFGHANISTAN.
AT THIS POINT, THEY ARE 30 MILES
AWAY.
ANALYSTS SAY THEY COULD FALL
WITHIN DAYS, AMERICAN TROOPS ARE
ON THEIR WAY TO EVACUATE THE
U.S. EMBASSY.
THEY FLEW INTO THE CITY JUST
THIS AFTERNOON.
BUT IT'S EARLY.
I LOOK FUNNY THING IS, DIDN'T
SEEM TO SEE ANY OF THIS COMING,
HIS REAL EXPERTISE AS HE
EXPLAINED RECENTLY TO CONGRESS
IS SOMETHING CALLED WHITE RAGE.
THE TALIBAN BY CONTRAST ARE
SLIGHTLY TEN OR SO THEY DIDN'T
SEEM AS DANGEROUS IN THE JANUARE
TALIBAN VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP,
SO NATURALLY UNDERESTIMATED
THEM.
BUT OTHERS SAW VERY CLEARLY WHAT
WAS COMING.
THREE YEARS AGO, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND THEY HAD
INFLUENCE OVER JUST HALF THE
COUNTRY.
THAT'S IT.
IN OTHER WORDS, AFGHANISTAN HAS
BEEN UNSTABLE FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
ALWAYS COME ACTUALLY AND YET THE
PENTAGON REPEATEDLY TOLD US
OTHERWISE.
WE ARE ON THE RIGHT TRACK NOW.
FOUR YEARS LATER, ANOTHER
GENERAL, "THEY ARE WINNING.
SO BASED ON THOSE CONFIDENT
ASSESSMENTS, OFFICIALS IN
WASHINGTON SPENT MORE THAN
$130 BILLION ON NATION-BUILDING
THERE.
FOR SOME PERSPECTIVE, THAT'S
MORE THAN WE SPENT ON THE ENTIRE
MARSHALL PLAN IN EUROPE AFTER
THE WORLD WAS DESTROYED, SO YOU
HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF WHERE DID
ALL THAT MONEY GO?
THE PENTAGON OF COURSE ISN'T
REALLY SURE WERE ALL THAT MONEY
WENT BUT INTERNAL DOCUMENTS
SUGGEST IT WAS WASTED.
REMEMBER THOSE?
THEY MAKE IT CLEAR A LOT OF THAT
MONEY WENT TO THE MOST CORRUPT
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY.
THOSE DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT ONLY
ABOUT TWO IN TEN AFGHAN RECRUITS
COULD READ OR WRITE.
THAT MEANT AMONG OTHER THINGS I
CANNOT RELIABLY FOLLOW ORDERS
AND APPARENTLY THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN.
FOR YEARS, AFGHAN COMMANDERS
HAVE ROUTINELY POCKETED TAXPAYER
MONEY FROM THE UNITED STATES
WITH SO-CALLED GHOST SOLDIERS,
APPEARED ON THE PAYROLL BUT
DIDN'T ACTUALLY EXIST.
ONE RECENT ASSESSMENT FOUND
BETWEEN 50 AND 70% OF POLICE
POSITIONS WEREN'T REALLY LIVE,
THEY EXISTED ONLY ON PAPER.
DOES MARK MILLEY KNOW THIS?
THE TROOPS WHO DID EXIST
SOMETIMES USE THEIR WEAPONS TO
COMMIT CRIMES AND SHOOT AMERICAN
TROOPS OR OFFICIALS.
AN OBSERVER ESTIMATED THAT OVER
30% WOULD TAKE THEIR GUNS AND
SET UP THEIR OWN PRIVATE
CHECKPOINTS TO EXTORT TRAVELERS.
BETWEEN 2007 AND 2013, THEY
KILLED OR INJURED HUNDREDS OF
COALITION TROOPS.
THESE WERE SIGNS OF A MAJOR
PROBLEM.
OTHER SOLDIERS AGAIN WITH MONEY
THAT WE SENT THEM BEGAN TO
SEXUALLY ABUSE CHILDREN.
ACCORDING TO A PIECE IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," "RAMPANT
SEXUAL ABUSE OF CHILDREN HAS
LONG BEEN A PROBLEM PARTICULARLY
AMONG COMMANDERS WHO DOMINATE
MUCH OF THE LANDSCAPE.
THE PRACTICE IS CALLED BOY PLAY
IN AMERICAN SOLDIERS AND MARINES
HAVE BEEN INSTRUCTED NOT TO
INTERVENE.
IN SOME CASES NOT EVEN WHEN
THEIR ALLIES HAVE ABUSED BOYS ON
MILITARY BASES.
SO ALL OF THIS IS GOING ON BUT
THE PENTAGON MAINTAINS PUBLICLY
EVERYTHING WAS GOING ACCORDING
TO PLAN YOU CAN SEE WHERE COMES
AS QUITE A SURPRISE TO THOSE OF
US WHO TOOK THOSE ASSURANCES AT
FACE VALUE, JUST A COUPLE OF
DAYS AGO THAT THE TOP AT THE
PENTAGON THE INCREASINGLY
RIDICULOUS JOHN KIRBY INSISTED
THEY HAD TURNED THEM INTO A
PROGRESSIVE UTOPIA IN
SANTA MONICA IN THE MOUNTAINS.
>> WATCHING THIS FROM A VERY
EARLY PERIOD RIGHT AFTER THE
PRESIDENT GAVE US THE ORDER TO
DRAW DOWN, WATCHING WHAT THE
TALIBAN AND IS DOING, WE HAVE
NOTED WITH GREAT CONCERN THE
SPEED WITH WHICH THEY HAVE BEEN
MOVING AND THE LACK OF
RESISTANCE THEY HAVE FACED AND
WE HAVE BEEN NOTHING BUT HONEST
ABOUT THAT AND I WILL LEAVE IT
THERE.
>> Tucker: SO TODAY, BECAUSE
ON THE PEOPLE OF AFGHANISTAN TO
RISE UP AND FIGHT FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE, THE WOMEN'S RIGHTS
VICTORIES, THE AFGHAN GOVERNMENT
SECURE.
RIGHT.
MEANWHILE, THE ACTUAL COUNTRY IS
COLLAPSING AT HIGH SPEEDS,
PICTURES RIGHT NOW THAT THE
TALIBAN NOW CONTROLS SO THAT'S
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS WORTH OF
RESISTANT VEHICLES, HUMVEES,
DRONES AT THE PENTAGON LEFT
BEHIND IN AFGHANISTAN ALL OF IT
NOW BELONGS TO THE TALIBAN.
SOMEHOW, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS IN CHARGE.
THE U.S. EMBASSY SAYS "WE ARE
HEARING ADDITIONAL REPORTS THEY
ARE SURRENDERING AFGHAN TROOPS,
DEEPLY DISTURBING AND COULD
CONSTITUTE MORE CRIMES.
HILARIOUS.
SO WHO'S GOING TO RUN THE
TRIBUNALS?
BUT INSTEAD, HERE'S ANOTHER
IDEA.
LET'S FIGURE OUT HOW THIS
HAPPENED.
DO WE SPEND 20 YEARS, TRILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN LIVES END UP WITH
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING BUT MORE
HUMILIATION, TRIBESMEN SHOOTING
AT US WITH OUR GUNS AS WE RUN
AWAY.
THAT IS THE DEFINITION OF
DISASTER SO RATHER THAN JUST
COMPLAIN ABOUT IT, LET'S HOLD
SOMEBODY ACCOUNTABLE FOR IT FOR
ONCE.
HALF OF THEM HAD A HAND IN OUR
FAILED POLICY YET THEY ARE STILL
EMPLOYED THERE.
WHY IS THAT?
THE PENTAGON WAS SUPPOSED TO
BUILD A FUNCTIONAL NATIONAL ARMY
IN AFGHANISTAN TO PROTECT THE
GOVERNMENT AND THEY DIDN'T DO
THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T DO THEIR JOBS
AND I MIGHT ABOUT NOT DOING
THEIR JOBS STILL WEARING THE
UNIFORM OF OUR COUNTRY, WHY IS
THAT?
GOOD QUESTION.
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG
TIME, MAYBE WE CAN HOLD OUR OWN
LEADERS TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
CALAMITIES THEY HAVE CAUSED